of course we would like to start off by
thanking the Academy and all of its
members who voted for us this is an
incredible honor and we can't begin to
believe that we are here right now
especially among our fellow winners who
each and every film knocked us out in
ways that we could never have expected
so congratulations to you all as well um
to Columbia Journalism school we are
forever grateful and everybody there
thank you for helping us and inspiring
us along the way to our funders who
believed in our film early on the
Pulitzer Center and the National Academy
of Television Arts and Sciences and the
New York Chapter thank you to Judith or
our advisors who run our program thank
you for your countless hours your
patience and your effort at every every
turn of this story - Betsy West our
editor-at-large or insight and your
advice is incredible and we are forever
grateful to Dan and our entire
documentary class back at Columbia
thank you so much for your endless
support and your guidance throughout
this year um we love you guys too our
crew which is Josh and I but -
re-recording mixer at Campbell thank you
for believing in our film and spending
such an incredible amount of time on it
- our composer and my dear friend Aaron
Gettleman you are so incredible talented
incredibly talented and we thank you and
to our colorist Adam greenberg also my
close friend thank you so much and to
Jude / Mueller who thank you for your
contribution to the soul of this film
and to the Khans family we are forever
grateful oh we have to of course thank
our executive producer pamela hogan who
gave as much of her heart to our film as
we did and she was extremely patient
with us and very kind and encouraging
and we
you and thank you for everything of
course um sorry I have a list of people
here all right don't
oh no okay here we go okay uh-huh it's
somewhere it's by my seat I'm sure I
have to I have to thank my sister's
Terry
Amy and Stacy and their kids AJ Haley
Brooke Adriana
Chris and Leo it was the cutest person
here see right now he's wearing a tuxedo
it's this big he's adorable
I have to thank Neil Curtis Curtis
Coleman and my best friend and the woman
I love Bianca Hayward and I have to
thank my dad who's here as well who flew
here from Florida living a comfortable
life in retirement and and my mom Debbie
who made it here today which I'm
extremely grateful for and I would like
to thank first and foremost at least
shorts my close close friend for
introducing us to the kinds and changing
our lives and there's forever
um do you my parents my mom and dad Mike
and Lisa oh this is harder than I
thought it was gonna be
thank you for believing in me always for
allowing me to sleep on your couch at
4:00 a.m. because your apartment was
closer to school than mine you are my
biggest fans my biggest role models I
would not be up here without your
constant love your pride and your joy to
my brother Danny my sister-in-law
Samantha and my one-year-old niece
Caroline me never stopped believing in
me never stop supporting me never
stopped offering me of mice or just
being there I throughout this entire
process I'm so lucky to have you and I
love you all
it's my la family Pat Frank and Joe
thank you for letting me turn your home
into my Edit Bay for two weeks tree and
for your constant support and love to my
best friend Mike you are my rock you're
my biggest support system thank you for
leaving me and for being proud of me
no matter how many late nights I spent
in the Edit Bay when my brain was in
pumps from places you amaze me and I
love you and now to the most important
people the kinds Marianne Brian Margie
you opened up their lives and your
hearts to us not knowing what this
journey what the khamar really who we
even were your trust is something that
has guided us and motivate us throughout
this entire making of this film
thank you for sharing with us in the
deepest and most intimate parts of your
life you are incredible and if you guys
can please come up here to you all you
sorry for a little long there's two of
us so it's a little harder but Brian
Charles and Thomas you are smart you are
brave
you inspire thank you for allowing us to
come into your lives and to share that
with the rest of the world never stop
believing in yourselves and from my part
I would like to dedicate this award to
Jonathan Resnick who's near and dear to
my heart who inspired me to start this
crazy journalism journey so long ago
from the beginning I miss you and I know
that you're smiling up there somewhere
yeah thank you for indulging us I know
where two of us so longer than you might
expect but we can't we can't step off
the stage without also without also
saying a thank you too
no thank you sincere word of gratitude
to all the journalists around the world
who put their lives in danger to tell
the truth and to speak truth to power
and the people around this country who
do the same and who stand up every day
to do the right thing we wouldn't be
standing in front of you if we weren't
journalists first in filmmaker second
and we wanted to say thank you to all
those folks out there thank you
[Applause]